The thriller joy has,
has some sort of a connection to just
the idea of accomplishing something that
is set out to do and on Wall Street that
happens to be a big trade or a big deal.
It could be creating a beautiful
painting if you're an artist or a,
a lovely ceramic,
um,
if,
if you're,
um,
that kind of an artist or a sculptor and
on Wall Street,
the,
the measure of sort of accomplishment
and achievement aside from the bonus and
the money that is attached to it is,
is all of those little transactions that
happen along the way.
Um,
and so there's a real connection of I'm
talking to a client discussing a
particular trade or a particular type of
transaction that they should do going
back and forth on meetings,
going back and forth on phone calls,
going back and forth on numbers.
And then like coming out of that with
achieving this goal of,
of closing that deal.
Because there's also a lot of
competition.
So when one team from one company is
trying to like a Morgan Stanley or
Goldman Sachs or jp Morgan is talking to
a corporation,
say a coca cola or an alcove or,
or whatever,
everyone's competing.
Um,
it's not like Goldman is the only
company talking to say Coca Cola or
whatever on,
on any given day,
there's,
there's a lot of teams and there's a lot
of competition.
So what comes out of that for people
involved is,
is the idea of having some help
accomplish the deal and sort of beaten
out of the competition.
So it's all very,
that's why it's such a very hyper
competitive environment.
And some people really continue to get a
thrill out of that forever,
um,
or throughout their full careers and
stay for a long time ago up a high chain
and keep going.
And some people didn't.
And I was one of them think that's,
you know,
also quite empty because you're not
actually creating anything.
You're accomplishing a close of a deal
perhaps what you're not actually
creating anything real or contributing
anything real.
Um,
and there's a real emptiness to that.
So it,
it,
it goes both ways depending on really,
I think the person.